I just want to recap what we did in this lesson and
remind you of the iterative process of sketching a visualization.
We started with our bar chart.
Notice that while it does some things well, such as highlight when games were
not held, it doesn't really convey the trend in time that well.
And also it looks a bit strange since the bars are so
thin, since they represent only one year.
We then went to a scatter plot, which shows the trend a little bit better,
as we can follow the circles as they rise and
fall, captures the missing years in which a game was not held.
But not nearly as well as the bar chart.
But is typically used to represent things where the values on
the x-axis aren't necessarily correlated or ordered.
While the scatter plot has some of the benefits of the bar chart and
some of the benefits of a line plot, it does a bit of a mediocre job at both.
We then tried to iterate with a line plot, since it is most suited for
time series data, and conveys trends very well.
Here we can easily see the trend in attendances over the history of
the World Cup, but tends to obscure dates where there was no data or
a game was not held.
So to remedy this, we're going to add our scatter dots back in
to show that because of where lower two, there were no World Cups games held.
And then to make the data points, in this case the circles more striking,
we can style them with CSS to make them red.
And to add context, we added a title.
I kept the title in here the whole time through the duration.
Since it's usually a good practice.
You start with both a title and labels on your axis.
So that even though the visual display of your data may not be the perfect
ideal, you or a reader still has the sense of what data you're looking at.
And that concludes the live coding example I wanted to go through.
And hopefully, you have a better sense of the process involved with reaching
a final graphic.